[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are going down the
rabbit hole watch out now
using new methods
who knows what we're going to talk about
today who knows who's going to drop in
sure we might have somebody special real
special drop out somebody special who
who said they were gonna drop in they
had something they wanted to say and
because
their kin
you know I can't I can't deny his
requests might be oh his it might be
your son one of your sons nope
um you have a rogue hair
how's that
I mean here's the thing I think it was
fine when it was down but I know that
you would want me to tell you thank you
so if it falls down again is it up you
know it's up but I'm gonna give you I'll
tell you two more times Max okay happens
just give me a fourth time let's not
make this part of the podcast let's just
make it a signal you know this is good
this is this is for the people who are
just listening and like I gotta watch
that YouTube version I gotta see little
things in there like that link
I thought you did it on purpose for that
reason uh yeah so we're gonna go down
the rabbit hole but before we go down
the rabbit hole we're gonna go into the
bear cave
that's my way of saying that I'm gonna
tell a story about a bear oh
spoiler
uh
so recently and here's the thing I
already told you this story and can you
just act like I haven't I was going to
typically I wait to say things but we
were in this Mixed Company situation and
I really needed to tell you the story I
need to tell somebody else in the store
and I was like I just don't want to do
the ear biscuits thing where I hold it
for a few weeks and when you say Mixed
Company what do you mean by that you
know uh people who you do a podcast with
and people you don't is that what you
mean what does Mixed Company usually
mean mixed company I I thought was like
winning it's like co-ed yeah yeah yeah
yeah
um I mean it was in that sense it was it
was a co-ed group yeah there was all
types of genders there and uh everyone
was well I don't know if everyone was
represented
you know everyone wasn't represented
right now yeah how's that even possible
yeah that's true I don't know yeah I
mean you know I don't even know why I
said mixed company I don't know why I
made it about representation people who
are my friends
and you
it's a good story I'm gonna hear it like
it's the first time good okay so I uh
Jesse and I took a little weekend away
with our friends Lance and Lacey uh you
know our long time friends who
responsible for uh you know Mixed
Company the beard the beard and Lady
products uh that we sell our grooming
line that's right uh been friends for a
very long time probably 15 years now and
uh they were coming into town
and we were like hey let they're coming
to town without their children so we
were like jackpot hey why don't we them
leave our child jackpot for you and uh
and go
just go to the mountains let's get away
from this heat it was that crazy hot
heat wave weekend yeah we had recently
uh so we just went to a place that was
probably 20 degrees cooler which was
nice
in the woods yeah and it is not uncommon
when you visit these places in the
California mountains that there's lots
of you know if you're doing an Airbnb
there's all kinds of information that
you're overwhelmed with when you arrive
at the Airbnb and in this particular
case some of that information
you mentioned bears but like more
mentions than seem necessary like it was
in the email it was in the handbook it
was a sign on the door on just all kinds
of stuff like do not leave any food
outside
or else
you will be fined forty five hundred
dollars good gosh
because there are bears in this here
neighborhood
and they are hungry bears
and I'm like okay well yeah
yeah I mean theoretically
right theoretically
so we uh
this is the first night we we you know
we hang out we eat some food
we leave
food out on the side and outside on the
kitchen counter like we had brought food
like some fruit some chips stuff that
doesn't go inside the refrige and stuff
that's not gonna go in a cabinet it's
just like kind of out on the counter
yeah but they said don't leave the food
they said don't leave it outside
um
so we didn't do that now the way this
place was set up is that it had what I
believe is like a south facing
almost a complete glass wall like four
sets of sliding doors and then a bunch
of Glass on top so like it's Southern
facing like just window you know get the
view of the valley that's a great way to
face and um that's a lot of sun in
yeah but you're not blinded by the Sun
on a set or a rise
it's more of your career you get it
throughout the day correct uh so when
it's cold it really warms it up that was
really irrelevant and irrelevant Point
well let's not start pointing those out
but in your story so we go we go to
sleep and we're sleeping in uh in two
separate rooms you know other couples
are okay each couple is in a separate
room it was that kind of it was that
kind of thing where do you each get your
own bedroom
and Lindsay and Lacy said to us
you know we tend to get up a little
early also time change you know they're
uh on the Central Coast Central Time
Zone Central Time Zone and
so you know we'll be quiet but we might
get up a little bit earlier than y'all
like 10-4
probably didn't actually say 10-4
probably just said okay
but then
it's like seven o'clock in the morning
and this is vacation time so seven
o'clock is very early and we begin to
hear
wow somebody's really making a racket
upstairs and if I may you know if you
hadn't mentioned bears at all
I'll just point out you know I'm not
trying to tell you storytelling 101 here
but like if it were me I probably
wouldn't have mentioned bears at all no
because my Preamble wouldn't have been
about bears the tension but here's the
thing I got people hooked they haven't
fast forwarded through this oh you were
afraid okay
you have to make a choice yeah you could
I mean did you see how big Brian and
Logan's eyes got when I said Somebody's
running upset that happened yeah out
there on the airwaves too I mean you got
to choose your battles right
so now everybody's thinking that you're
about to get in a bear point of the
story so in my I would advise you to to
you're kind of my left turn you're
cripping my style at this point yeah
yeah
um they're like wow okay they said they
they said they might be up early but
this seems disrespectful
the level of loudness seems
disrespectful you know what are they
doing up there it was probably them
though and uh now cut to Lance and Lacey
in their own bedroom
saying to one another
right and Jesse
we didn't think they were gonna get up
we didn't think that they were gonna get
up this early and be making this kind of
racket
at which point Lance gets up and goes
into the main area of the house which is
like a living room a dining room and a
kitchen all open together floor plan
nice he sees
a bear no way
no hold on what in the kitchen no it was
outside okay I see you but I got you it
was a bear
standing on the deck
standing up with its hands on the screen
ripping through the screen to get right
next to the handle to get to the handle
to open the handle of the sliding glass
door to come inside and get the food
that it smelled and I guess saw on the
counter the bananas and chips and I said
how big was said first of all he sees
the bear he goes he says to Lacey it's a
bear
and he goes about to get his phone and
when he comes back the bear is gone
so the bear did not get inside but the
bear was actively trying to open the
door bears are smart they're trying they
know how these things work so it took it
basically ripped in fact I just texted
because I didn't get a picture I texted
Lacey and Lance to see if they got a
picture of the screen they just he just
shredded the screen if we had that
you're seeing that in the YouTube
version now but honestly I don't know if
we have it but what is it I mean was it
like did was the whole screen ripped off
or it was two spots on the screen were
four strips like like a bear claw and
then a spot that it just ripped through
right next to the handle to get to the
handle of the glass door it was
shimmying the handle it's and thankfully
we yeah that was what was making it was
great it was grabbing onto the handle
and trying to get it open and thankfully
we locked all the sliding glass doors
and we put the reinforcement like you
know the little like wood rods to keep
the doors from opening
and uh we were like what dad gum that
bear was really coming in I mean these
people weren't lying I mean if you would
have left the door unlocked and the the
rod out the bear would have come in yeah
he would have walked into a bear just
like beating the nanner well the story
is not over my friend because we get up
we have a we have a laugh about the bear
we begin to realize that the bear may
come back
um but I my theory was that the bear was
making its rounds and make it makes its
rounds and tries things and opens things
to see if and if people are there I mean
it's not like people have been killed by
bears in this place that we're at I I
don't think so I don't think there's a
history of a bear attack or something
that wasn't in the booklet or on the
door or in the email but you don't want
to be the first and you don't want to
find out
but
about an hour later
we decided we would walk outside at
which point the first thing I see when I
look outside is our car
and the the driver's side door to the
car is open
that's a good feeling at that point I
remembered another thing that I read
which was lock your car doors
if he's going for a sliding glass door
knob
so I'm like I know we didn't leave that
door open but I'm pretty sure we didn't
lock it because I drove and I've gotten
completely spoiled because the car that
I drive
is tied to your phone so once you get
about 20 feet away from my car it
automatically locks so behave and so
basically what ends up happening is that
when I drive Jesse's car I never I
forget to lock it because I'm like oh
isn't it supposed to do this when I get
20 feet away anyway spoiled
so I'm so this has got your fault
written all over I'm approaching the the
SUV and the door is open you creeping
right and we got tinted windows and we
tinted them too much probably beyond the
legal limit so I can't see into the back
damn you're living on the edge and I'm
like what are the chance the bear was
just here what are the chances that I'm
gonna go up to this car and the Bear's
gonna be in there
I mean uh at least 50 maybe yeah because
it I believe it was in there at one
point I creeped to the car I stop I wait
I'm assuming that there's going to be
some sort of movement that the Bears did
you like throw a stick at the car no I
just thought if there's a bear in there
it'll be rummaging and I didn't see any
motion so I go up and I just open the
door a little bit more because it was
like half closed look in
no bear but the first thing that I'm
thinking is I've seen these pictures
about what bears
of what Bears will do to your car they
they they'll pry open a door like taking
the lid off of a can and not just that
when they get into your car typically
what will happen in fact there was a
picture at the General Store in town and
it said Bears versus car and it said
lock your car doors and it had these
pictures of the Interiors of cars that
had been verified and they just go in
there and they smell like a goldfish
that your kid dropped into the seat
cushion and they ripped the seat cushion
up to get to it
thankfully I guess kids are older old
now and we only got one at home now
the only thing that I could find is
there was dirt on the the driver's seat
because it had gotten up with his Dirty
Paws and then it had gone into the back
seat and there was one
claw Mark where it kind of like went in
kind of deep on the on the leather seats
punctured it didn't completely go
through and I am I think I am showing a
picture of that right now unless it's
like bounced back but that was the only
evidence that I could find that it was
in there and it definitely was in there
and then it and then it left
in the back seat too yeah it like I
think it went over and like looked in
the back seat and probably smelled
and then decided I cannot believe that
your car was not ripped to shreds oh so
I mean
had you cleaned out your car I mean like
I'm not trying to dog on you here but
like I've been in this is Jesse's car
right oh yeah I thought it was Jesse's
car I mean Jesse's car has it's just
it's an it's a it's an accumulation zone
for like I mean mostly not food though
it's like design samples and like tile
and a bunch of carpet samples and
curtains yeah it's like a design woman's
car you know Designing Women remember
that show that's what it's just like
what you imagine the inside of their
card but no smoothie remnants no like
granolas and yours Justice I'm so
surprised as you you were spared dude
that was I mean
especially there's signs everywhere it's
like
every time every point in the story I
thought you're done telling me about
signs there's more warnings it's like
this is definitely on you well and we
kept thinking that the bear General
Store we kept thinking the bear was
gonna come back
you know but they can open doors oh and
there was Zero evidence of a bear claw I
mean I don't know how to open some doors
well like your your Tesla would have
been imperviously because I don't know
how to go I would say a Tesla is like
bear proof and I don't know how to get
out of it either and maybe that's the
whole point like I pulled the thing that
a normal person would get out of the you
know anything and then you're like oh
you're supposed to push don't pull the
thing that normally would get you out of
the car push the button it looks like
it's supposed to roll the window down I
didn't design the car that's what opens
the door I'm not defending but it also
rolls the window down a little bit so it
rolls the window down and opens the door
a little bit Yeah like what yeah so
bring the Bear in I didn't know how to
get out of this thing but it's all they
have to do is stick their hands up under
the handle and just pull and they have
figured it out like they're bare hands
they have completely figured this out
that's why inside the house the trash
cans
had
just the trash cans inside the house
under the the uh like under the sink
were bear proof had bearproof Lids on
them so that if it happens to get in it
can't like because they they know they
just know how to open stuff and create
some weird way that they can't get into
things
anyway I survived thanks for thanks for
being concerned
um but yeah those bear warnings those
bear warnings are
I don't think I've ever
I don't know I've actually had a bearing
counter I I have you have in my own
backyard I mean it's like the Bears turn
over the trash cans and but did you
pay a fine I mean if it's forty five
hundred dollars
did you did you did you did you report
this to the people oh yeah we well them
getting into my car no I mean the the
the the door like the The Ripped door
yeah but we didn't do anything wrong we
didn't do we didn't violate any rules
leaving food on the counter is not a
problem but so you you had a
conversation with them I actually right
before you started recording it hit me I
said I texted Jesse because it was her
Airbnb account and I said
did you ever tell the owner that the
reason the screen door was ripped up and
ripped off was because of a bear and she
was like yes I told him okay so they
knew also just weird side note but kind
of cool first Airbnb I've ever stayed at
where
they had merch
there was a closet full of hoodies and
t-shirts I stayed here and survived a
bear attack and it said did you forget
um did you you know did you forget a
sweatshirt or something like that just
take one home and let us know and we'll
add it to your bill and it was like a br
it's it's like a company that owns the
house or something I guess okay but
anyway it was pretty cool Jesse got one
she because Jesse and Lacey did uh I
guess because they're pretty nice
hoodies and they were I mean they sell
them for 40 bucks that's a pretty good
price it's not bad for a hoodie yeah
I mean if you go if you go to a show I
went to the Kendrick Lamar concert you
buy I mean 100 for a hoodie yeah easy I
mean it had it had two naked people on
it 50 50 each yeah
and they were I think it was either a
tie they were on a tiger rug
yeah did you get one uh for my son yeah
to wear to high school you got them
naked people on us no I didn't I just
made a lot of jokes about it well so I
don't know which one I'm getting you and
then I was like none because it's a
hundred dollar hoodie it's like you have
a t-shirt
nope the line was too long honestly I
was like you know what I don't like
anything that he's got up here so I
don't want to wait in line
you don't Kendrick doesn't have good
merch he didn't have great merch in in
my opinion that's a surprise yeah maybe
it's too too ahead of his time probably
you know it'll be cool three years from
now I mean don't get me wrong all of his
merch is classic it's just it's just I
don't find myself going back to it
that's what I would say about his new
album show was awesome yeah 100 it's but
I got inspired I was like Lincoln
honestly if I really like something I
would get in line and I would get it and
then I'd probably get you something too
but at this point if you really want
something you need to buy it with your
own money and standing in line by
yourself and I don't think any of this
is Worthy
and he was like yeah so I basically
talked him out of him trying to talk me
into buying him something hmm
sometimes you just need a t-shirt for
the memory though I I like to get a
t-shirt at a show but I just couldn't
find anything that actively appealed to
me
it's a shame surprising it was a shame
but you enjoyed the show I love the show
yes
did anybody open traded for the world
baby Keane his cousin
they produ they you know he came back
out and they did a couple of songs
last night of the of the of the U.S tour
how old is the baby Keem how old is baby
Keem he's he he's he walks he can walk
he can he can talk he can rap in
complete sentences so he's at least
five okay but if he appears to be much
older than that
how old does he appear to be uh he
appears to be in his mid-20s maybe 30.
wow it's hard to tell okay that's an old
baby definitely not much of a baby hmm
I don't know I bet you he's in his 20s
how old is baby King 21 he's 21. okay
he's still baby he is still a baby I
said he could be 30.
you know it's like it's it's it's
dramatically lit on stage
you know I was within nine years that
ain't bad but you didn't see a bear of
course I didn't really eat it no the boy
you had me on the edge of my seat
I was wondering if when a bear was going
to show up hey
we're going to mythicon you might not be
able to make it we understand but we
want you to share in the experience of
the first ever mythicon so we are making
our stage show which is a Cornerstone of
the mythicon experience a live streaming
ticketed event that you can enjoy from
the comfort of wherever you're comforted
yeah so this is the Saturday night
October 29th show
this is going to be a weird show I'm
just going to be honest with you you're
doing something that yeah we're doing a
number of things on this stage that
we've never done before and we will
probably never do again and so we were
like not because it didn't work but
because it's special it's just gonna
yeah it's just gonna be
once you do it once I mean we're gonna
do it we're gonna try something we're
gonna try something that may have
incredible results we're taking some big
risks a big risk and um creatively and
logistically existentially I would say
that we are taking some big risks and
um we're taking you into account yeah so
and so in order to make sure that every
mythical Beast has an opportunity to be
a part of what we're doing that night
we're partnering with kids we to host a
live ticketed live stream event okay
survive twice yeah well I want to make
sure you know it's live uh pre-sale
tickets available now for all mythical
Society members and then we're gonna
have the general sale starting on
Wednesday okay
um join the mythical Society get your
tickets today
mythicontickets.com
mythicontickets.com live stream link you
know last second for your record uh I
experimented with a couple of uh
conversation starting websites and I
have uh since up my game did a little
research okay
I've upgraded
to what random questionmaker.com still
not a sponsor okay
uh random questionmaker.com but this
lets you set the tone of the question
what do you mean what do you mean you
can select from
candid
weird Icebreaker creative and funny so
of course I went with weird great okay
so I'm gonna I'm gonna ask you a weird
question I'm gonna ask us a weird
question okay
I don't know why this is weird
what is the best job you ever had that
ain't weird this one
uh besides this job what's the best it
doesn't say that no it says what is the
best job you've ever had
um
this is the best job I've ever had
this is definitely the best job I've
ever had
um second best job I've ever had is not
an obvious choice
turns out I really haven't liked jobs
I mean for me this feels like a pretty
easy answer it has to be our time on
staff yeah we can't be yeah you're
basically doing kind of what we're doing
now yeah I agree with just with the
Jesus twist yeah give me another that
was just not that weird yeah I know it's
weird that it would ask that question so
strange
it wasn't weird
why is have you ever been in a car
accident or seen one no I've never seen
one
I've never seen it
no this is interesting because you were
in a pretty
were you with your mom in that car
accident no
my mom broke her back I was not in the
van yeah okay you are there uh so what's
the most what's the craziest accident
you've ever been in is it the one that I
was there for
uh you're talking about the the
Halloween egging
that's the craziest car accident I've
ever been in
my head broke the windshield
yeah that was that was my doing
yeah yeah I think I mean that was scary
that that was that was kind of traumatic
it was very shocking I mean we're egging
houses with our friends I don't
recommend that it's it's me
and you and in my 1987 Nissan pickup
that I still own at my mom's house yeah
and Heather sitting in the middle uh of
the bench seat and then how many people
are we seeing now I'm still gonna say
eight eight people eight people in the
back three people in the front you know
we you egg people's houses and then you
flee the scene and it's it had been
raining a little bit and leaving this
neighborhood that I I never go in
you know what's it called uh it was
really nice really nice and anger and
then
so I didn't see the stop sign until it
was too late and then it was
um the road didn't continue straight you
had to turn right or left when you
stopped at the stop sign which I was
going through and I don't know
35 miles an hour so I
45 yeah 50. so I I slammed on brakes
until I realized that like oh there's
just a field out there so then I was
like we're just going to go into the
field but there was like a huge ditch
that well bam we like go down into this
ditch and then we hit so we had so much
momentum that like we hit the ditch and
then popped up on the other side and
like came to rest in the field and when
I looked around
the front my front windshield was
cracked thanks to your forehead well in
my perspective I get into the car
after having thrown eggs uh and of
course when you're in an egging
situation and you're getting in and out
of your car you don't put your seatbelt
on also it was like 1995 in North
Carolina I mean you didn't wear your
seatbelt that much anyway we were dumb
and so no one in the back was wearing
seat belts yeah all the people in the
back so I just was basically just a free
fall not free fall but just a free throw
like my head boom right there on the
part of your head that you would head
butt someone with hits the windshield
completely shatters the windshield
I come back to the seat I think
Heather's head hit the middle part and
knocked the mirror off yeah she comes
back
and then the car sort of comes to a stop
and the first thing I did was laugh
because I was in shock to some extent
but I was in shock that this had just
happened and I wasn't hurt but then we
heard the crying and wailing and I
looked over to my right and left and
like the people the friends of mine who
were in the back of the truck are now
all in the field
we thought we had killed people I
thought I tossed everybody out but they
had just jumped out in Terror but my
ex-girlfriend at the time she was like
I'm bleeding she's bleeding I'm bleeding
all over my face and we look we're like
it's egg you have egg all over you
you're not bleeding of course one guy
was
bleeding because he had the worst injury
shout out to Don he oh okay yeah Don and
Brooks they both were seated against the
back of the calf so they hit the they
hit the back
of my back windows of my truck and and
broke those and broke their their their
face but I think they both have
permanent face scars did Brooks have a
permanent face car I believe I knew that
Don had one
um yeah Don definitely has a face scar
from that that's that's that's my worst
uh Story look you got that one out of me
again yeah and I was there so and it was
so weird here's another weird one
I think maybe it's weird I think that
maybe this would be weird we're just so
weird if you were just like an idiot if
you were on a date because it would be
weird to ask what's the size of your
shoes what
yeah that is really weird on like a
first date there's like a lull in the
conversation and you're like
size of your shoes
like just pick one left or right just
what's the size well mine are a little
bit different my left one's a little bit
bigger mine too but it's not worth
getting a half size difference
um Brett thank you for asking such a
weird question I wear a size at 11.
I wear a size 11.
and for the longest time you also wore
an 11. we have the same size shoe you
are you went up to a 12. didn't you you
wear 12. uh I have always been I've been
a 12 for many many years I've been at 12
cents since uh high school and and I
have uh 13s in Pumas
okay consistently Puma's a little bit a
little bit tight on the 12. so I go 13
on Pumas
I wear a yeah a ten and a half two at
eleven and a half it depends on the
brand
um okay oh that was I'm I'm sorry it got
a little weird there I was talking about
like our shoe sizes I switched to
creative mode this is a creative
question come on let's try this do you
believe in Bigfoot
absolutely not no no
do you no no I mean my insurance I'm
just checking and seeing if you've
changed your view I I'm cool with it I'm
cool with Bigfoot and I could be wrong
but like no no I mean they're
discovering species all the time but
they're like deep in a jungle that is
not a sasquatchian jungle and they're
like small things
you know there's there's more bugs that
we don't know than we do
so I'm I'm kind of making an argument
for like
a small Sasquatch in the Amazon but that
ain't Sasquatch
here's
I definitely do not believe in Bigfoot
right there's just absolutely
No Good Reason to Believe In Bigfoot
however
at this point I don't think I could be
presented with evidence that would make
me believe in Bigfoot do you know what
I'm saying it's right it's so
unbelievable at this point that if
somebody was like we have definitive
proof of bigfoot I just too late I don't
think there's I don't think you could do
anything to change my mind which I'm
just I'm just saying that that's how
made up my mind is about this particular
thing
I it's yeah crying wolf too many people
have cried Bigfoot there's been too many
TV shows about it where they haven't
produced a Bigfoot yeah you think a TV
show Searching for Bigfoot if they could
find a Bigfoot they would have
you know you think they'd they'd hold
back on that maybe to get a couple more
seasons out of it but eventually you got
to show a little bit of the Bigfoot
you got you got to I haven't even
invested but let's let's talk about Yeti
though because I I have the classic
conversation with um you believe this is
different a fella oh this is very
different
so like I dropped I was picking up Lando
from his flag football practice and
they're like I got to know the other
parents we're like you know we're
hitting it off I'm telling you I meant I
found I found a new friend group right
I'm just telling you it's my son's
parents they're a good group of people
your son's parents that would be you oh
yeah that's me my son's friend's parents
I left a friend out yeah that makes more
sense yeah I do like hanging out with
myself oh you could be talking about
your wife you know and there was a there
was a guy sitting there in a chair in a
folding chair and he was like and there
was an open one so I sat in his other
chair
I don't know why he brought two it was
only him but I guess to share
I was like damn this is a this is a nice
chair I look back at it and he said yeti
on it this is one of them Yeti chairs oh
okay and then he's like William yeah you
know I've I traveled to so many
different things and I have to sit down
I wanted to splurge and give myself a
nice chair I was like well you know
Yeti's where it's at before you know it
we're having that Dad conversation about
everything that you should get from not
a sponsor Yeti
oh I got the cooler that goes on your
back and well you put ice in that thing
three days later it's still ice you know
this is these are the conversations that
you get in when you're in full dad at a
flag football game mode so you're just
saying you believe in Yeti as a brand I
believe in Yeti as a brand I think you
can count on Yeti but you're gonna have
to Fork some dough to get that Yeti you
know what I'm saying do you own any Yeti
products on a Yeti cooler you do yeah
that I that I got for my solo trip and I
don't think I've used it since then
because I just don't have many cooler
needs people you know it's we're in an
age where like products come out of the
woodwork that are like super specialized
and then they're advertised on Instagram
and it's basically thinking of hey you
can you're gonna pay out the nose for
this but we've done all this work to
figure it out like I'm getting a lot of
Instagram ads for all types of bags well
have you seen hoverglide no the bag that
I've seen is one that is like it's it
looks it's got four zippers across a
duffel bag
I don't know what it's called again not
a sponsor and it's like so each each
compartment
you can you can organize things in
different ways and it's like very
it's very anthropic I think you're going
to want this
and then there's another bag I saw where
it starts off and you're like you put a
suit in it and then you roll it over and
turn it into a duffel bag I've seen that
look at this and what's this guy doing
floating backpack it's the hoverglide
this is invented by a professor like a
biology Professor from so the backpack's
on your back and as you move like as you
walk or jump or anything the backpack is
like on some sort of spring system so I
actually so I already watched this whole
patented technology it's a it's it's uh
on a track that this is the guy that
invented it and it has these bands these
elastic bands it looks like it looks
like the backpack is staying completely
motionless as you're moving up and down
Dr Lawrence I'm a biology professor at
the University of Pennsylvania he's been
working on this project for the past 15
years yeah you know what it is though of
course this came out in 2018. it's a
steady cam dude haven't you ever seen a
Steadicam operator yeah but why how come
this hasn't caught off
did the pandemic ruin all momentum that
this floating backpack had because that
could be me and you right there running
across the city square and our
backpack's just staying completely
motionless as we go up and down that
could be me and you man we could be
doing jumping jacks on the steps why
does he keep doing jumping jacks because
it's a great way to illustrate how this
works yeah but I don't do jumping jacks
with a backpack well they say it like
reduces the load like about 80 percent
you know I don't know if it's true
but I'm just saying if you're if you're
into bags I would think that you might
have this one if you started rolling
with this backpack this backpack that
makes it I'm not in the bags what you
just said you were getting advertised
bags okay so you're sending the wrong
messages to Instagram I look at them
you're right I guess proof's in the
pudding I freaking look at these ads
listen but I never buy the bag the
robots are smarter than you robots know
you better than you know yourself the
robots know you want a bag
and you might want this bag I don't know
I don't know you man hey red and Link
y'all got time to talk to me oh yeah we
always had time to talk to you hey Dad
thanks for joining us
yeah
I don't I don't know about these two
boxes but you know you you you probably
could I don't know whether you need to
get one made out of a cooler or not you
just go to Lowe's and get a good toolbox
that's what I see that's what I was
talking about a toolbox they was
listening he was listening he was
listening is that why you called what I
was told that you wanted to call in
but not not I didn't want to call in to
get in between y'all's toolboxes I
called in to try to help people to uh
know about dispatches from Myrtle Beach
okay I gotta I got a little tear motive
so so you want to pull everybody from
this podcast into your podcast and you
know what hey that's fine by me I'm just
kind of conveniently involved in both of
them uh yeah and I'm uh in full support
of you listening to both of your
biscuits and dispatches from Myrtle
Beach
well that that's what we want to try to
get people to do let them hope to keep I
know they're going to keep watching
their business we try to get trying to
get that many people to watch dispatches
from Myrtle Beach because we having a
good time and Swinging stuff around the
world and we might might even teach you
how to dance or something oh yeah I've
learned quite a bit yeah there's a lot
to learn
yeah but I I do know looking at the data
that there's
there's roughly like four times as many
people listening to ear biscuits as to
dispatches from Myrtle Beach and Dad how
do you feel about that
well y'all been doing that a lot longer
than we've been doing dispatches so okay
that's true maybe in about about about a
six months just give a sick about six
months and we're gonna see if we can't
catch y'all get pretty close anyway okay
so right now we're gonna we're gonna
work hard at this so right now there's a
if somebody listens to your biscuits
there is you know four people listen one
person
says I'm also going to listen to
dispatchers from Myrtle Beach but in six
months
you're saying all four of them are gonna
listen uh all five of them oh more
people yeah
I don't know it's you know it's uh yeah
it's it's good for everybody if you can
tolerate a dirty joke or two
yes once in a while yeah we we have some
people ask some funky questions huh
and I mean we've been taking a break so
it was like four weeks off for us have
you missed making the show
oh yeah I like doing it it's fun but I
don't know if I'm gonna let us take a
break again like this oh
[Laughter]
I told you right he I told you he read
asked me it's like are you are you are
you making your dad do this I'm like hey
he likes it
he likes it well you seem to be enjoying
yourself
oh I enjoy it's fun it's kind of like
well
people some people know about uh SOS is
society shaggers it's a shagging thing
that we have for about 10 days down here
in the fall and my shirts came in that
said do you know who I am
yes and uh that's what I asked people a
lot of times if and it's really got to
do with uh
you and Link read I said you know who
Rhett and Link are and uh but this
lady older than me walked up to me and
read my shirt and she says I don't know
who you are
I said and Nancy was with me Nancy said
what he's got a famous son and a man
that works with him is famous and they
do stuff on YouTube and stuff you're the
man that works yeah
yeah well y'all work together whatever I
mean heck no I I understood I'll take
that but
uh but she she didn't know who good she
didn't know what good mythical morning
was but I did tell her about dispatches
from Myrtle Beach yeah yes on a podcast
so you know I that's just my job when
I'm talking to people yeah good it's
called vanilla marketing guerrilla
marketing
and that I mean if dad takes his shirt
off it would definitely be like gorilla
marking it because he's hairy
hey that's like the people I talked to
on the beach that day and asked about
you too and then all I had on was my
swimming trunk and a cold beer in my
hand by the way but anyway and dad would
you be willing to take your shirt off
and have uh dispatchers from Myrtle
Beach shaved into your body hair
no yeah you got to draw the line
somewhere I'm going no no what about
your email address
not that either rather be shagging 53
aol.com
it's harder to read yeah yeah and uh you
get you got any emails
yeah I got one but if we gonna do a sign
we'll just get another t-shirt made up
with all that stuff on wing and we ain't
doing that to my chest
yeah just get a t-shirt made before you
you guys have been shaved into your
chest hair yeah yeah but I I have got a
uh question that Randy Johnson sent in
to us and he the picture you
well no it you know it don't say that
but that I know who I remember that
Randy Johnson that was about six foot
about as tall I think he was taller than
me yeah yeah he was about 16 or 6 11 and
could throw heat he could throw heat I
guess he's a fan of the show
yeah it might be but if you guys make
too much of a connection over baseball
then you're gonna have to have your own
baseball podcast okay
and red you know you go you're gonna
with all the hair you got you're gonna
like this okay
it says what do you call a smiling Roman
soldier with a piece of hair stuck
between his teeth
a smiling Roman soldier with a piece of
hair stuck between his teeth I know it I
figured it out
I know it
okay
um
is it got the word Centurion in it well
you can try try
just give it a shot
what do you call a Roman soldier
smiling with with hair in between a
piece of hair made a movie about it
okay
yep okay so it's got something to do
with gladiator
oh
Gladiator
that's it there you go
there you go yeah and that was it
sometimes sometimes I give a good hint
real once in a while
but why did you say would someone as
much hair as Rhett
he would like it because hey because you
know if he was like that Roman soldier
he wouldn't know if it was here he has
her hers that was between his teeth okay
well a lot of dispatchers from Myrtle
Beach is the struggle and discovery of I
enjoyed you you want me to join no yeah
we got to keep the fun between us it's a
bonding thing I don't need to be there
just every once in a while you know like
right now yeah you can join us you know
every once a quarter or something rich
until we get enough of the audience to
move over I think we're just gonna have
to keep getting you to join this podcast
wow dad uh so I mean I don't want you to
share any more of the jokes you got to
keep your best stuff for dispatches oh
don't worry I got some stuff I got some
stuff for starting this coming week boy
I mean I've I've been recognized that
about
six or seven places
and uh he always get you know he always
tells a story yeah well no I didn't tell
the story in half of these places they
just recognized me oh yeah it's
happening
all right well save it save it for our
our recording session again dispatches
from Myrtle Beach comes out this coming
Thursday
and um yeah then we're back every
Thursday but Dad can you talk directly
to your biscuits listeners again three
out of four have not given it a chance
yet so just can you speak directly to
them give them your
uh wholehearted
pitch well all you ear biscuits fans I
would really like for y'all to start
watching dispatches from Myrtle Beach
because don't say watch because it's
only audio I mean listen and uh to
everything uh
on dispatches from Myrtle Beach because
you might learn some words that Gene
never heard before if you're just coming
just want to just listen to me talk and
just see what you can learn about it so
and listen we have a good time and uh I
got an email address rather be shagging
53 at AOL.com that you people on ear
Basics and send us send me some
questions and I'll do my best to answer
them and see what we can do with that so
just come on and swing I always like to
tell people we swinging around in this
show like while I'm swinging when I'm
dancing so just come on and have a good
time from your biscuits to dispatches
from Myrtle Beach
rather be shagging the letter B no G on
shagging the numbers five three at
AOL.com and it's not much of a time
commitment right I mean you guys you
guys keep it under uh you keep it under
40 minutes right that's 30 30 minutes
every episode 30 minutes yeah you can
add it to your life it will make you
happy
I tell you Dad you make me happy every
single week I I feel it's good I've
missed it was good to see both of y'all
I'm telling you I get to see you you
know with what we do but uh
and I reckon it'd be hard to me to say
you knew I I'll be glad to be seeing
y'all and down in Austin Texas in the
end oh yeah uh oh yeah we're looking
forward to that yeah we're having a good
time at mythicon
I'm telling you so uh we've done a
little stuff with that too so uh looking
forward to that
yes
you know getting the bond a little bit
and have a good time yep
and get more listeners all right Dad
that was a very effective plug if that
doesn't do it I don't know what will
well no notes you no notes I I try to do
the best I can do to do what we we
enjoying doing so if I need to I'm gonna
let y'all get back to here biscuits and
talk about tool boxes or something yeah
yeah yeah yeah we'll pick up where we
left off all right Dad I'll see you soon
for our uh for our next recording
okay all right love love both of y'all
love you too bye bye isn't he the
greatest yes he's just he's just so he's
a natural he's so he's he's just falling
right into it
you know he's completely he's completely
embraced it yeah he's found a new
calling
um he hasn't quit his day job yet
you know well maybe still painting if
you get enough listeners still painting
you can do that we'll get there
um I do have a question for you is it
weird uh uh it this one's it's under the
weird category but to me it's more
interesting than weird
um
if you were offered the position of
Mayor of your city would you take it
um this mayor of Los Angeles or Burbank
mayor of Burbank
being a politician
in any that just seems like a nightmare
to me you know it's like I I respect
people who are who can who do it and
it's especially if they keep their
integrity intact
you know but like being in a position
where you've got to please the people
you know it's like we have fans that we
have to we we you know if they're not
happy
this Arrangement isn't working but at
the same time it's not 100 of our job to
make people happy
you know
it is a big part of it but you know what
I'm saying like something about it's
it's just like being a politician is
like a
if you're doing it right it's a complete
Act of service
and that's just
I mean I guess I'm too selfish for that
I think very I mean maybe I'm being too
cynical but I don't think we don't have
to have these headphones on anymore oh
let's take these off
look at us
look at us taking the headphones off
um I don't think
are we good just keep going
okay
I don't think
most people
get into
politics
for selfless reasons right
um
even I mean you can
as a service there can even be a
selfishness in being selfless you know
it's like if you find joy in being
selfless isn't that selfish
thank you
like Mother Teresa you know wanted he
wanted to get up and help people because
every morning because she found uh
fulfillment in that if you want to get
to the root of it I would say that yeah
if you follow if you actually are
following your you're making decisions
for your own benefit and for your own
well-being
most often you will do good things to
other people right like most people will
will end up oh I'm doing good because it
makes me feel good I don't think there's
anything wrong with that no but I guess
what I'm saying is this is an
interesting question because
I've heard somebody say relatively
recently actually that you know we spent
a lot of time thinking about national
elections and we you know everybody like
if you're going to vote you vote for the
presidential election and you'll right
you'll vote for some other things right
but actually to affect chain now first
of all we believe in that vote for the
national elections we go to vote
likeabeast.com get registered to vote
whatever that is we believe in that but
really you have a lot more power in your
vote at a local level right
and right I'm I'm a bit cynical when it
comes to politicians in general and I
think many of us are right
because you think about it
you you got you know sort of the you've
got the Senate right just a hundred
people
and
that's a pretty impressive position to
make it in in politics like
if you make it to the Senate like that's
a big deal House of Representatives a
little bit easier right and I think it's
reflected in the
um the nature like the vibe there's some
people in the house that are just
absolute nuts I mean there's people in
the Senate who are nuts too but there's
some people in the house that are just
like how how does this person become a
national politician a representative and
then you go even lower than that and you
get into like state legislators
yeah you can get pretty freewheeling the
people who make a series of life
decisions where they find themselves in
a position to run for local office
you know this isn't necessarily the best
and the brightest so I mean I'm not I'm
just saying this is I'm I'm just saying
that but those elections
if those people are actually really
really important so when it comes to the
mayor of your town I mean because it's
one thing to say like mayor of Los
Angeles or Burbank they're like just a
mayor of your average town like that's a
really important I think it's a really
important position
you know what I'm saying yeah I'm a
little too intimidated to to sign up for
that even in in a small town seems like
I don't know it's it's I couldn't see
you doing it either
well I mean I jokingly talk about
political campaigns all the time
um because I'm I have just enough blind
confidence to get to a place where I
feel like I've got something to say uh
and could motivate somebody and maybe I
could believe in something enough where
I felt like you know political will was
the most important part of it
uh but I'm I I'm never gonna allow
myself to to uh to do that do you have a
recommendation I do
um I think by the time you hear this you
will have seen um
Justin long as a guest on Good Mythical
Morning yes and he was there to promote
his movie Barbarian it's a scary movie
the horror movie that I saw last night
yeah let me tell you it was so good
oh it's it's so scary and it's funny and
it's creative the way that it was done
it was just kind of innovative and kind
of keeps you on the edge of your seat
and Justin long is great in it he's just
he's really funny he just plays a
complete a-hole but he plays such a good
a-hole
and uh I just highly recommend it if
you're into horror movies when he came
on the show when he first met us he
looked at you and he said
you look like
one of the henchmen from Superman 2 and
he went and what was the guy's name well
he went on to say you know it was zod's
henchman he's like it's almost uncanny
it's almost uncanny
and then we pulled up
it was not Zod it was this guy non non
non just grunted non from this just and
it was not a complicated Justin Long
called yunan but then and I will say
there is a resemblance henchman to Zod
uh yeah the real guy's name is Jack
oh
snap
Halloran that sounds like Witness
Protection
oh he had a he had a lot of uh yeah he's
he's quite a character actor look at him
I do have a passing resemblance like he
could be my brother
uh but because he went on to say you
look like him but I mean you're you're
more handsome because whether he like
brought up a picture
he's like a handsome version of him
handsome version of nine I didn't hold
it again keep returning the favor uh but
see the Barbarian who's great in that
move
we'll speak at you next week remember to
call us give us your responses and we'll
play them at the end 188 earpod one
hashtag year biscuits hey Rhett and Link
uh probably already a little late to
this one but I just want to let you guys
know that I was 25 when I learned that
zippers block I didn't know this if you
put them all the way down they lock and
you can't pull open your pants have a
mythical day are you ready I just wanted
to say that I listened to almost every
podcast and it's crazy to see how the
podcasts have grown but I recently well
not so recently went to therapy because
both of you proved to me that nothing
has to be wrong with you to go to
therapy and little did I realize that
throughout therapy the anxiety and
stress were going away and listening
through podcasts and growing was you
felt amazing and I'm so proud to say
that my therapist even says that I
graduated from therapy now I followed
out kind of going through a breakup with
my therapist but it was amazing and I
just have to thank you too for being
there along the side with me and uh I
guess you might think you're my new
therapist
let me tell you something red you wrote
a hell of a blues tune there kill a man
I'm telling you what my name is Hunter
I'm out in Michigan I just got to tell
you what man I'm proud of you this album
is freaking awesome okay
keep doing it put out another one get
link on that Matt love you guys
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
foreign
[Music]